a
[Música]
esta fashion week' 2021-2022 femenina
otoño-invierno está demostrando que
parís sigue siendo la capital mundial de
la moda
primero porque dura 10 días más que
milán londres o nueva york pero también
porque tiene planificado 93 desfiles
todos virtuales ya sea como un desfile
tradicional detrás de internet o en
forma de películas para ello la
federación de la alta costura ha estado
mano a todas las redes sociales desde
youtube pasando por tick tock hasta
redes sociales chinas tienen estáis los
desfiles comenzaron con uno de 48
alumnos de último curso del instituto
francés de la moda para demostrar que
este país sigue siendo líder en la
formación en el diseño y en el lujo hay
desfiles de las tradicionales marcas
como chanel louis vuitton y dior pero
también muchos nuevos creadores entre
ellos varios japoneses como la casa
rural o wataru tominaga lo cierto es que
esta fashion week' en pandemia está
haciendo sobre todo una oportunidad para
jóvenes creadores que trabajan en parís
pero que jamás podrían pagarse un
desfile de moda en cambio si pueden
pagarse una película es el caso del
chileno octavio pizarro que presenta
playa
en las costas chilenas
[Música]
en el norte de italia la ciudad de milán
se convirtió en el epicentro mundial del
glamour con la semana de la moda que se
concluyó este lunes esta es la tercera
iniciativa de este tipo que se organiza
en tiempos de pandemia durante siete
días las más prestigiosas casas de moda
presentaron sus últimas colecciones en
pasarelas casi siempre sin público para
evitar el riesgo del contagio 61
desfiles transmitidos todos en directo
por internet entre las presentaciones
más destacadas la de la firma italiana
prada caracterizada por la yuxtaposición
de estampados colores y materiales
diferentes o la colección de giorgio
armani con siluetas casuales vestidos y
pantalones anchos pero siempre con un
toque de elegancia la industria de la
moda ha sido un sector particularmente
afectado en italia por el impacto
económico del coronavirus con pérdidas
estimadas a unos 29 mil millones de
euros en el año 2020
[Música]
la inauguración de la semana de la moda
en nueva yor este año ha estado en manos
del diseñador jason wu el modisto ha
apostado por una presentación presencial
algo que no se ha visto mucho en la
ciudad la mayoría de las presentaciones
de nuevas colecciones han sido de manera
virtual debido a la pandemia en un año
en el que se han echado de menos grandes
nombres dentro del mundo de la moda como
michael course calvin klein ralph lauren
que no han participado en este evento
además el consejo de diseñadores de eeuu
ha decidido cambiar el nombre de la new
york fashion week la semana de la moda
en nueva york por calendario de
colecciones americanas en un intento de
alargar el evento hasta mediados de
abril y no concentrarlo todo como se
había hecho hasta ahora en una misma
semana así que los diseñadores tienen
hasta mediados de abril para presentar
sus colecciones como por ejemplo lo hará
hoy mismo el diseñador óscar de la renta
[Música]